Welcome back everyone this will be
my brand new aquaman 2 batman video
that's right we just got our first look at ben
affleck's batman in aquaman 2 so big surprise
he's in the movie we've also gotten some actual
footage from the movie recently too so i'll talk
about that during the video as well if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there's still a ton of
comic con trailer footage that i'm working
through so i'll try to get that stuff out
as fast as possible it's hard to tell if
jason momoa dropped this on purpose because he
posted all these pics in this video on social
media like this is the video of him revealing
that ben affleck's batman is in the movie
well we tried to keep it secret
all right there we go thank you
sorry bro
whoops
well even though i wouldn't totally put it past
him i think he's just kind of playing us a little
bit like he meant to release that and it's in
lieu of them not coming to comic con like oh
yeah we do have some cool stuff going on batman
is in our movie by the way james wan kind of did
the same thing like hey sorry i didn't come to
comic-con with a brand new trailer but here's
some behind-the-scenes stuff that we did recently
because normally they would hold stuff like this
till the actual movie came out because it's a
pretty big surprise the only reason why we found
out about ben affleck being in the flash movie is
because like a special behind-the-scenes article
and some footage that they were filming in broad
daylight otherwise they probably would have waited
to one of the last trailers came out dc kind of
skipped comic-con this year they brought the black
adam movie they brought the shazam 2 trailer video
but we didn't get a new aquaman 2 trailer video or
a new flash movie trailer mostly just because
they delayed those movies to so late next year
even though there's been a lot of crazy stuff
happening with dc movies lately especially with
all the buyouts and all the superman talk about
him coming back the reason that all the dc movies
got delayed just a little bit is because mostly
aquaman 2 just was not ready its visual effects
needed way more time so everything else basically
just got bumped a couple months but what looks
like it's actually happening is we're gonna get a
big bruce wayne cameo during aquaman two probably
to address the post-world status of justice
league snyder cut with the team working together
across each other's films those will probably
want to have as many crossovers as possible just
because it kind of helps boost each movie a little
bit we might see him in his batman costume we know
he's going to be in the batman costume during the
flash movie but we don't know if he's actually
going to be in the batman costume during aquaman
2 like we just see him in his bruce wayne gear the
reason he's in the flash movie is mostly to give
him his new multiverse suit like that suit you
see the flash wearing and all the trailers that
comes from ben affleck's batman there's also a big
emotional bookend with batman in the flashpoint
movie but that's a story based reason for ben
affleck to be in the flash movie aquaman doesn't
really need batman for technology the same way
that the flash would like all the technology that
he has access to in atlantis is way more advanced
than surface world technology so it's not like he
needs ben affleck to give him his new stealth suit
or anything like that so you can post all your
theories about what he's actually doing in the
movie he might help him out with some information
that he doesn't necessarily have access to or
something special that he wouldn't be able to get
in atlanta's the bigger news i think is that he's
going to be in more dc eu movies besides the flash
movie originally the flash movie was going to come
out before aquaman 2 and there were a lot of very
reputable news organizations saying that that
was going to be his last hurrah in the dc eu like
flash movie cameo and that's it but now because we
know that he's an aquaman too we know that's not
the case now they did switch the release order so
like the flash movie could be like his last big
cameo scene for a while but i think the idea is
that they're not going to kill him off even though
they have all this crazy flashpoint stuff going on
he'll still exist in the dc eu and they'll just
bring him back for cameo scenes or for whatever
he wants to do in the future anytime that he does
want to come back otherwise he wouldn't come back
for this aquaman 2 cameo scene but now breaking
down all the stuff that's in that aquaman 2 teaser
trailer video the title of the movie is the lost
kingdom as in the lost kingdom of atlantis there
are seven kingdoms of atlantis we only saw six of
them in the first movie so this movie is all about
revealing what happened to that lost kingdom
they mentioned it in the first movie they said
before the lost kingdom had been lost when they
were talking about the great fall when atlanta
sank into the ocean so atlantis is the name of
the city where aquaman is ruler but it's also
the name of the nation of atlantis of a bunch
of different kingdoms that broke apart when it
sank into the ocean it's atlantis itself the city
then zebul where mira and her father are from the
trench the brine the fishermen and the deserters
as the name implies the deserters was that desert
location in the sahara desert where they went to
find the information on where to find the lost
seat so they could get king atlan's trident in his
armor for aquaman so that he could take the throne
but as you guys saw during this footage there was
a brand new scene or an old scene however you want
to think about it of king atlan fighting which
probably has something to do with the lost kingdom
the way they do the logo reveal the trailer reveal
the breaking of the ice implies that it's located
in a polar region like either in antarctica or
somewhere trapped inside a glacier also earlier
this year you may notice when james won was
teasing the movie he was posting pictures when
they were filming they were inside what looked
like an iceberg or a glacier and the title or
the working title of the movie was necrus so what
is necrus it's also called the black city it's
basically a lost city that's like atlantis but
that only exists on planet earth for brief periods
of time and sort of shifts between different
dimensions and that's why it's lost not only is
it inside a glacier but it's also shifting between
dimensions the flash movie is sort of invoking the
multiverse in the dc eu in a really big way so
i don't know if they're going to take that route
with it in the movie they might just say that it
got lost inside a glacier and that's why nobody
found it most of the concept art and the teaser
focuses on this brand new place like you see them
on top of this iceberg here getting ready to dive
in to go find the entrance you see them inside
this very different looking city that doesn't look
anything like atlantis this is probably inside
the lost city you see what looks like this whole
underground ecosystem which is probably preserved
inside the lost city and all these new kinds
of creatures they encounter there in most of
the footage that they feature here it seems like
ocean master has been let out of his prison like
aquaman goes to get him in the beach here when he
looks like robinson crusoe with this giant beard
like he's pulling a tom hanks castaway situation
with this giant beer like they trapped him on land
because what would a prison be for an atlantean
you trapped them on land instead of trapping
them underwater and he's just been by himself on
this island since the events of the first movie
but then you see him after a haircut in the same
kind of gear that aquaman is wearing and they're
both fighting black manta's people together
so even if there's still a little bit of beef
between them it sounds like they put most of the
past behind them i think that was the idea of the
end of the first aquaman film like look dude we're
brothers so let's put this behind us water under
the bridge to make an aquaman metaphor whereas
in the aquaman post credit scene they revealed
that he had been found by dr steven shin who's an
aquaman villain of sorts in the comics he's both
an ally and a villain to aquaman saves his life
and then basically vows his revenge so in service
of that you probably noticed how everybody got
redesigned costumes everybody got upgrades even
aquaman himself you think that the armor of king
atlan would be enough no we need a bigger upgrade
the whole thing with black mantas costume is that
it just got destroyed in his fight with aquaman
so it makes sense that he would want to retune
his weaponry his helmet his armor just to be a
little bit better for the second round the whole
thing with aquaman's brand new costume i know
it looks kind of dark what's the deal here most
people are referring to this as his stealth armor
like something is going on with the lost city and
he needs a cell suit for whatever mission they're
going on the movie is going to be really big so
there'll be a couple sub missions couple side
quests during this too like you see them running
through the desert like they go back to the
kingdom of the deserters to get more information
on the lost kingdom so it's not like they're just
going between atlantis and the lost kingdom
they'll visit some of the other seven kingdoms
as well we only briefly saw some of them during
the events of the first movie because the working
title is necrus. Necrus is the black city they're
implying that it's the lost kingdom of atlantis in
the comics the ruler of necrus was a person named
so i don't know if they're going to change that
for the movie because in a big movie like this as
silly as they might get with some of the moments
is comedic a name like just feels a little
too silly and in the comics his whole ammo was
very similar to ocean masters in the first movie
you know forming an alliance to fight the surface
dwellers but since we did that in the first movie
i'm not expecting them to recycle the plot of the
first movie for the second one there's a whole
bunch of stuff going on in this scene of james
wong talking about the movie like zoom and enhance
around the background of his little office here
most of this is all just concept art of people
from the lost kingdom like soldiers from the lost
kingdom with new technology aquaman's new costume
his old costume from the first film the armor of
king atlan and i know a lot of people saw this
shark here and they're like wait a minute is that
king shark is there going to be a king shark cameo
in the movie from the suicide squad because that
would be amazing i'm not going to hold my breath
on that but that would be one of the few cameos
from the suicide squad movie that seems like it
would be an easy slam dunk for an aquaman film
they haven't completely explained the timeline of
the movie i believe it's supposed to take place
within a couple years of aquaman taking the throne
so he's been king of atlantis for a couple years
now when they learn about what's going on with the
lost kingdom there's some big threat that requires
them to go find it and as a lot of the footage
implies that might have something to do with what
black manta is doing during the movie black manta
co-opting more atlantean technology and possibly
more weaponry from this lost kingdom during
the first film they did reference the events
of the justice league film just for continuity
but you didn't really see any huge characters
running around on screen talking to aquaman
just a lot of playback on televisions and a
lot of news clippings and references the real big
dceu crossovers are mostly happening in the flash
movie because it's a multiverse movie and you have
michael keaton's batman coming from the multiverse
with ben affleck's batman also probably shazam
too i also talked about this during my black
adam video because everybody's kind of wondering
what's happening with superman and so many of the
different dceu actors that still have movies
that are happening want to do some sort of big
crossover with other characters particularly
superman wonder woman right now just based on
the way people are talking the best chance for him
coming back would be inside the black adam sequels
if he's not already in the first black adam movie
but obviously this whole aquaman 2 teaser is just
meant to be an early look at the film they'll be
a much bigger trailer next year like they've been
filming they still have a lot of work to do in the
film that's why they didn't show full trailers for
all the dc movies if you have any big questions
or you spotted any big easter eggs during this
that i didn't talk about in the video just write
them below in the comments i will do a new video
for that black adam trailer that they released
at comic con and i just did a shazam 2 trailer
video that i'll put a link for in the description
click here for my brand new black panther wakanda
forever trailer video and click here for my
non-spoilery house of the dragon episode 1
review thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!